Theatre matters because democracy
matters theater is the essential art
form of democracy and we know this
because they were born in the same city
in the late 6th century BC the idea of
Western democracy was born it was of
course a very partial and flawed
democracy but the idea that power should
stem from the consent of the governed
that power should flow from below to
above not the other way around was born
in that decade and in that same decade
somebody
legend has it somebody named Thespis
invented the idea of dialogue what does
that mean to invent dialogue well we
know that the festival of Dionysius
gathered the entire citizenry of Athens
on the side of the Acropolis and they
would listen to music they would watch
dancing and they would have stories told
as part of the festival of Dionysus and
storytelling is much like what's
happening right now I'm standing up here
the unitary authority and I am talking
to you and you were sitting back and
you're receiving what I have to say and
you may disagree with it and you may
think I'm an insufferable fool you may
be bored to death but that dialogue is
mostly taking place inside your own head
but what happens if instead of me
talking to you
and Thespis thought of this I just shift
90 degrees to the left and I talked to
another person on stage with me
everything changes because at that
moment I'm not the possessor of truth
I'm a guy with an opinion and I'm
talking to somebody else and you know
what that other person has an opinion
- and it's drama remember conflict they
disagree with me there's a conflict
between two points of view and the
thesis of that is that the truth can
only emerge in the conflict of different
points of view it's not the possession
of any one person and if you believe in
democracy you have to believe that if
you don't believe that you're an
autocrat who's putting up
democracy but that's the basic thesis of
democracy that the conflict of different
points of views leads to the truth
what's the other thing that's happening
I'm not asking you to sit back and
listen to me
I'm asking you to lean forward an
imagine my point of view what this looks
like and feels like to me as a character
and then I'm asking you to switch your
mind and imagine what it feels like to
the other person talking I'm asking you
to exercise empathy and the idea the
truth comes from the collision of
different ideas and the emotional muscle
of empathy are the necessary tools for
democratic citizenship what else happens
and the third thing really is you is the
community itself is the audience and you
know from personal experience that when
you go to the movies you walk into a
movie theater and if it's empty you're
delighted because nothing's gonna be
between you and the movie you can spread
out put your legs over the top of the
stadium seats each of popcorn and just
enjoy it but if you walk into a live
theater and you see that the theaters
have full your heart sinks you're
disappointed immediately because whether
you knew it or not you were coming to
that theater to be part of an audience
you were coming to have the collective
experience of laughing together crying
if they're holding your breath together
to see what's going to happen next you
may have walked into that theater as an
individual consumer but if the theater
does its job you've walked out with the
sense of yourself as part of a whole as
part of a community that's built into
the DNA of my art form 2,500 years later
Joe Papp decided that the culture should
belong to everybody in the United States
of America and it was his job to try to
deliver on that promise he created free
Shakespeare in the Park and free
Schaefer in the park is based on a very
simple idea the idea that the best
theater the best art that we can produce
should go to everybody and belong to
everybody and to this day
every summer night in Central Park 2,000
people are lining up to see the best
theater we can provide for free it's not
a commercial transaction in 1967 13
years after he figured that out he
figured out something else which is that
the Democratic circle was not complete
by just giving the people the classics
we had to actually let the people create
their own classics and take the stage
and so in 1967 Joe opened the public
theater downtown an Astor Place and the
first show he ever produced was the
world premiere of hair as first
introduced wasn't Shakespeare Clive
Barnes in the time said that was if mr.
Papp took a broom and swept up all the
refuge from the each village streets
under the stage that's the problem he
didn't mean it
complimentary but Joe put it up in the
lobby he was so proud of it and what the
public theater did over the next year's
was amazing shows like four colored
girls who have considered suicide when
the rainbow is enuf the Chorus Line and
perhaps even here's the most
extraordinary example I can think of
Larry Kramer's savage cry of rage about
the AIDS crisis the normal heart because
when Joe produced that play in 1985
there was more information about AIDS in
frank rich's review in the New York
Times than the New York Times had
published in the previous four years
Larry was actually changing the dialogue
about AIDS through writing this play and
Joe was by producing and I was blessed
to commissioned and work on Tony
Kushner's Angels in America and when
doing that play and along with normal
heart we could see that the culture was
actually shifting and it wasn't caused
by the theater but the theater was doing
its part to change what it meant to be
gay in the United States and I'm
incredibly proud of that
when I took over Joe's old job at the
public in 2005 I realized one of the
problems we had was a victim of our own
success which is Shakespeare in the Park
had been founded as a program for access
and it was now the hardest ticket to get
in New York City people slept out for
two nights to get those tickets what was
that doing that was eliminating 98
percent of the population from even
considering going to it so we refounded
the mobile unit and took Shakespeare to
prisons to homeless shelters to
community centres in all five boroughs
and even in New Jersey in Westchester
County and that program proved something
to us that we knew intuitively people's
need for theater is as powerful as their
desire for food or for drink it's been
an extraordinary success and we've
continued it and then there was yet
another barrier that we realized we
weren't crossing which is a barrier of
participation and the idea we said is
how can we turn theater from being a
commodity an object back into what it
really is a set of relationships among
people and under the guidance of the
amazing Laird of SMA we started the
Public Works program which now every
summer produces these immense experience
but Tony award-winning actors and
musicians are side by side with nannies
and domestic workers and military
veterans and recently incarcerated
prisoners amateurs and professionals
performing together on the same stage
and it's not just a great social program
it's the best art that we do and the
thesis of it is that artistry is not
something that is the possession of a
few artistry is inherent in being a
human being some of us just to get us
spend a lot more of our lives practicing
it and then occasionally
you get a miracle like Hamilton Lynne
Manuel's extraordinary retelling of the
foundational story of this country
through the eyes of the only founding
father who was a bastard immigrant
orphan from the West Indies and what
Lynne was doing is exactly what
Shakespeare was doing he was taking the
voice of the people the language of the
people
elevating it into verse and by doing so
ennobling the language and ennobling the
people who spoke the language and by
casting that show entirely with the cast
of black and brown people what Lynn was
saying to us he was reviving in us our
greatest aspirations for the United
States our better angels of America our
sense of what this country could be the
inclusion that was at the heart of the
American dream and it unleashed a wave
of patriotism in me and in our audience
the appetite for which is proving to be
insatiable but there was another side to
that and it's where I want to end and
it's the last story I want to talk about
some of you may have heard that Vice
president-elect pence came to see
Hamilton in New York and when he came in
some of my fellow New Yorkers booed him
and beautifully he said that's what
freedom sounds like and at the end of
the show we read what I feel was a very
respectful statement from the stage and
vice president-elect pence listened to
it but it sparked a certain amount of
outrage a tweet storm and also an
Internet boycott of Hamilton from
outraged people who had thought we had
treated him with disrespect I looked at
that boycott and I said we're getting
something wrong here all of these people
who have signed this boycott petition
they were never going to see Hamilton
anyway it was never going to come to a
city near them if it could come they
couldn't afford a ticket and if they
could afford a ticket they didn't have
the connections to get that ticket
they weren't boycotting us we had
boycotted them
and if you look at the red and blue
electoral map of the United States and
if I were to tell you oh the blue is
what designates all of the major
nonprofit cultural institutions I'd be
telling you the truth you'd believe me
we in the culture have done exactly what
the economy what the educational system
what technology has done which is turn
our back on a large part of the country
so this idea of inclusion it has to keep
going next fall we are sending out on
tour a production of Lynn Nottage is
brilliant Pulitzer Prize winning plays
sweat years of research in Reading
Pennsylvania led her to write this play
about the deindustrialization
of Pennsylvania what happened when
Steele left the rage that was unleashed
the tensions that runways the racism
that was unleashed by the loss of jobs
we're taking that play and were touring
it to rural counties in Pennsylvania
Ohio Michigan Minnesota and Wisconsin
we're partnering with community
organizations there to try and make sure
not only that we reach the people that
were trying to reach but that we find
ways to listen to them back and say the
culture is here for you too because we
in the culture industry we in the
theater have no right to say that we
don't know what our job is it's in the
DNA of our art form our job is to hold
up as twere a mirror to nature to show
scorn her image to show virtue her
appearance and the very age its form and
pressure our job is to try to hold up a
vision to America that shows not only
who all of us are individually but that
welds us back into the commonality that
we need to be the sense of unity the
sense of whole the sense of who we are
as a country that's what the theater is
supposed to do
and that's what we need to try to do as
well as we can thank you very much
[Applause]